a Las Vegas father accused of fighting a
teenager appeared in court this morning
we showed you that viral video yesterday
of 39-year-old Jose Montez he's facing
charges including child abuse battery
and coercion his defense attorney says
Montez went to pick up his son from Dell
H Robison Middle School where that fight
happened nearby
my understanding is the victim doesn't
even go to the school and can they
adjust to confront my client's child
when he got there he would have as soon
as in the process of being jumped and he
came in and got involved in it and
there's a lot of things that occurred at
that point hearing there for montez's
lawyer he will be on electronic
monitoring not allowed to have any
contact with the victim or the victim's
family eight news now spoke with the
victim's mother Melissa Rodriguez she
says she believes the fight was a random
confrontation